la marque Serrano merci on a vu qu'il
aymeric Caron voilà qui est souvent venu
nous voir propose l'interdiction des
corridas vous lui répondez quoi c'est
l'interdiction de de tout un art de tout
un rite de toute une culture mais
surtout une manière de vivre la fin
d'une espèce puisque c'est demain il y
en a plus de corrida il n'y aura plus
cette espèce qui est une espèce rare
c'est surtout qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que c'est pas un animal comme tous
les autres c'est un animal sauvage qui
se bat un truc qui se tue entre eux et
c'est tout un peuple du Sud et tout un
peuple au niveau mondial qui aime la
corrida ici c'était si
peu aimé il y aurait pas des millions
d'amis qui viendraient toute la
fictionnaire qui viendrait chaque année
au feria alors c'est Solveig je vous
présente mon épouse non non mais c'est
Solveig qui est là Solveig qui est qui
nous donnera son avis dans un instant
alors Cathy est-ce qu'on peut vous
décaler car Solveig va s'asseoir une
Solveig
[Rires]
mais vous inquiétez prudent après la
question
la question
faut-il interdire la corrida oui oui oui
Delphine Solveig vous inquiétez pas elle
va donner son avis tout à l'heure quand
on voit ses images déjà je trouve les
touradors là ils sont ils sont ridicités
c'est des hommes encore une fois je
pense et je te l'avais déjà dit à toi je
pense qu'il y a un problème de
masculinité là-dessus pour se pour ce
vanter bomber le torse avec des armes
face à une bête qui elle n'a pas d'armes
c'est un combat qui n'est pas du tout
égal et quand vous dites que les arènes
sont pleines enfin il y a quand même je
crois 74% des Français qui sont contre
donc il faut que ça évolue en son temps
il y a plein de traditions qui
existaient dans le temps dans le temps
couper la tête des gens aussi voilà
la justice faisait que on les
guillotinait aujourd'hui ça n'existe
plus donc il y a des trains
ce que je voudrais dire c'est
qu'évidemment vous l'avez vu sur la
vidéo ont eu un animal et ça peut
paraître violent en revanche ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'on tue des
millions d'animaux chaque jour jusque là
et voilà et que citez-moi un autre
animal qui est tué sous le regard et
Marc pourra vous en parler sous le
regard et sous le contrôle de 15000
regards 15000 personnes contrôlent
lorsque Marc va tuer le taureau 15000
personnes le regardent et si il rate son
les stocks si le tumal l'animal si la
mort n'est pas foudroyante et rapide
tout le monde va le huer il a ce poids
sur les épaules est-ce que dans les
abattoirs 15000 regards contrôlent la
mort de la minimale non où est la fierté
alors Marc Serrano matador d'abord ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est de l'animal
de laquelle on parle on parle pas d'un
animal domestique on ne parle pas d'un
animal correctement
on le voit quand même assez op on peut
alors je vous raconte une histoire qui
est vrai
que vous comprenez ce que un taureau et
j'habite tout le monde à venir au moins
une fois dans sa vie en élevage si vous
voulez pas venir courir vous n'y allez
pas et venir allez voir je vais voir
comment ça vie un taureau de corrida il
faut savoir qu'il se battent entre eux
qui se tue entre eux vous comprenez bien
les spécificité cette race j'ai vu des
taureaux se battre un il lui serrait
complètement marchant sur ces viscères
continuez à se battre jusqu'à la mort
rien que pour ça je veux que l'on
comprenne on est on aime pas mais que
l'on comprenne de l'animal dans lequel
parce que cet après-midi en fait
Raphaël très très mignon d'ailleurs
c'est le discours des gens qui
connaissent les taureaux
c'est 40 ans j'ai reçu 8 coups de cornes
j'ai trois cervicales avec les prothèses
et j'accepte de mettre cet animal en
mettant ma vie en danger parce que je le
respecte je ne me cache pas derrière un
fusil dans un abattoir ou quoi que ce
soit je le fais devant tout le monde et
j'accepte de mourir j'accepte de mourir
pour ma passion et par passion pour cet
animal parce que c'est un animal hors
norme et qui mérite une ordinne il nous
mordille pour moi c'est devant 20 000
personnes dans la lumière et avec une
personne qui va mettre sa vie en danger
comme lui donc c'est un combat équitable
alors vous avez quand même la longueur
des lances donc c'est pas tout à l'heure
mais vous dites
j'accepte de mourir mais le taureau lui
il a pas le choix monsieur moi je vais
vous dire à tous les deux tout
simplement à mes yeux vous êtes des
meurtriers voilà vous tuez pour votre
plaisir des taureaux qui n'ont rien
demandé c'est un meurtre rituel au nom
de la tradition vous êtes des barbares
je ne comprends même pas comment vous
osez vous exprimer c'est bien que vous
soyez là mais franchement c'est une
meurtrière vous tuez des taureaux pour
votre bon plaisir vous rendez compte
monsieur vous rendez compte abolissons
la corrida tout de suite interdisons là
moi je suis allé à quoi une corridor
mais j'ai vomi sur moi dans les gradins
moi je suis mal tombé le torero était
pas terrible une un coup d'épée qui
reste à moitié en dehors on la récupère
il la replante ensuite des sauts de sang
qui sortent par les narines il voulait
pas mourir ce taureau j'avais et moi je
me suis vomi dessus dans la tribune ça
c'est la première chose ensuite les
coutumes puisque on parle de tradition
la tradition on doit pas y toucher si si
bien sûr qu'on y touche à la tradition
je disais tout à l'heure après les
guillotine on a supprimé l'empalement
l'empalement c'était sympa aussi hein
bon il y a des tas d'autres choses qui
vont être supprimées la chasse à courre
pendant la chasse à courre la chasse à
courre ne peut pas perdurer c'est pas
parce que il y a une poignée de mecs
qu'on souvent assez friqués qui se
régale d'aller chasse à courre mais
c'est pas possible tu vois le cerf on va
jusqu'à épuisement total et une meute au
cul et Jean-Marie à la fin on le tue on
met des heures pour le tuer et le pauvre
sert des fois il met un coup de tête
encore dans la langue
il faut il faut il faut aussi comprendre
que on fait la tête et la queue oui les
oreilles à la queue
Turner un petit peu c'est le même
principe
non mais chacun son tour
donc voilà il faut savoir qu'on arrache
les oreilles la queue donc je demande à
ce que ceux qui le fasse subissent mort
quand le taureau est mort hein pas quand
il est vivant bien sûr donc en fait il
est temps les sociopathes qui s'y
exercent ce qu'ils pratiquent à Paris
serait en prison donc vous invitez des
sociopathes il faut savoir que monsieur
est à l'extrême droite bien sûr affiner
à l'extrême droite et que vous vous avez
été condamné pour pour diffamation non
pour l'agression vous avez accusé
d'agression sexuelle et il me semble que
vous avez été condamné en diffamation
non non on va pas rentrer là non mais il
faut il faut aussi rappeler que Madame
puisque moi je suis l'extrême droite qui
se retient et dans la corrida le meurtre
ne se retient plus celui qui m'a violé
torture des taureaux il fait des
spectacles entiers de soutien à la
pratique sa liste il a déclaré la
corrida est un art le sexe est un art
comme Eric dupont-morett comme Pablo
Picasso quand même c'est un aveu de
meurtre c'est un aveu de viol et il est
grand temps que le spectacle de la
cruauté de la barbarie la plus absolue
ne soit ne soit plus une vantardise car
derrière évidemment le couteau qui perce
la nuque
en privé en public en privé se
transforme en couteau qui coupe la gorge
et ça c'est son des millions et des
millions de bovins qui sont assassinés
tous les jours le monde entier est une
arène il est temps que le spectacle le
plus cynique le plus
complexé soit aboli et il va être aboli
car nous ne laisserons pas faire les
sociologues
parce que là c'est déjà compliqué Marc
bien évidemment je suis pas d'accord
avec elle parce que je veux pas beaucoup
le buzz ce soir désolé monsieur
on est enterrées
[Applaudissements]
que c'était une tradition du Sud et bien
que l'esclavage c'était une tradition du
Sud nous sommes en terre de torromachie
nous avons l'extrême droite invité en
place d'honneur et la diffamation et la
diffamation
moi j'ai jamais été condamné madame pour
rien vous êtes attendez c'est à suivre
elle parleront toutes très bien
qui qui fait l'apologie de la corrida se
vante de se branler devant les
documentaires de la Shoah c'est dans ses
livres il se vendent des règles
est-ce que c'est tradition doit
disparaître
pour la première fois sur un plateau ce
serait bien de l'entendre une tradition
puisque c'est la parole
qu'est-ce que vous avez à dire à un
matador en plateau c'est la première
fois voilà qu'on a besoin
la parole à un meurtrier c'est très
dangereux
je suis là pour être le porte voix des
martyrs des martyrs au vin des martyrs
taureau des martyrs des martyrs génies
vous voulez pas lui parler mon frère
vache ma sœur
extrêmement dangereux on les combats de
ce qu'il faut descendre dans les arènes
il faut descendre dans les libérer les
martyres
tu as raison
c'est pas possible et c'est parler les
autres fascisme
la parole
vous avez honte à vous est-ce que je
voudrais dire
non mais c'est chiant parce qu'on avait
on avait les protagonistes on a moi je
suis contre la corrida on a un temps
réel si on a un mec qui flotte arrête de
parler pour rien
arrête de dire des bêtises
on est avec toi
on avait un gars qui fait ça non mais
laisse-le parler le mec qui était là
c'est son métier de faire ça
mais qu'est-ce que tu me parles des
taureaux on avait le mec qui tue les
taureaux fini les mots il faut des gens
rouge à lèvres là c'est n'importe quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et tu des taureaux ça m'intéresse plus
que ton mascara ta main comme ça là
c'est relou
on est d'accord pourquoi tu laisses
partir c'est une pratique d'homme
sadique
des femmes magnifiques hommage à toutes
les femmes qui manifestent à toutes les
femmes qui a plein de femmes dans les
arènes qui regardent le spectacle il y a
plein de femmes dans les arènes alors
soldats est-ce que vous voulez discuter
avec Géraldine c'est une pratique
sadique ne me coupez pas la queue hein
on reprend ton souffle et je vais parler
pendant ton souffle 2 minutes
[Rires]
[Musique]
le problème c'est que vous êtes dans une
logorrhée assourdissante et mes pauvre
camarades qui ont dit oui finalement ben
moi je suis très content d'avoir dit non
défendu moi j'ai vu par exemple une
corrida une fois dans ma vie j'ai trouvé
que le spectacle était immonde je n'ai
pas du tout aimé j'ai pas du tout
apprécié mais pour autant je ne pense
pas qu'il faille l'interdire parce que
si vous demandez par exemple aux gens à
Arles aux gens à Mont-de-Marsan aux gens
à Béziers mais ils adorent la corrida il
y a plein de femmes pendant les arrêts
parce qu'ils adorent qu'il faut la
conserver
parce qu'il y a un rapport avec
l'esthétique avec la mystique
rien ne justifie la souffrance Mathieu
Mathieu
par exemple des combats de coq en
Guadeloupe en Martinique et bien sûr
nous interdirons le meurtre pour qu'il
soit mais madame soit et nous interdire
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
il est il est passé à la députés ils
n'ont pas parce que les députés ils ont
compris et on est en démocratie les
députés représentent justement le
territoire et les territoires de la
République et on l'a combat mais ça
marchera pas comme ça illégal en France
vous êtes une ayatollah de
l'antispécisme ça ne marche pas ils ont
aboli la corrida
elle est pas halloween
c'est passé là c'est pas une blague sur
le mec est-ce que vos actions est-ce
qu'on a quelque chose ou pas
c'est chiant on avait le mec [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va pas s'embrouiller avec
solveigres là non non non
elle avait dit qu'elle se calme en plus
ce soir vous l'avez promis abolition sur
l'élevage le m'élevage qui n’élève que
la douleur ou à chaque seconde depuis
que j'ai commencé dans l'exorcière
mais non on est avec toi
avec vos conneries Castaldi
ments
1 2 3 et il doit y avoir une prise pour
débrancher
alors Solveig est-ce que vous voulez
est-ce que vous l'entendre quelqu'un
de Monaco là sur le bras
mais c'est vrai c'est bon
position et ensuite ils admettent mais
on le fera malgré vous on le fera malgré
vous démocratie malgré à qui tu parles
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous voulez bien écouter
Benjamin Castaldi complètement
[Applaudissements]
c'est très à la mode
[Rires]
j'adore alors Benjamin
Solveig sur le plateau elle a comparé
les camps de la mort aux abattoirs pour
moi vous n'avez plus aucun crédit déjà
pour commencer ensuite excusez-moi
pour commencer
je suis là vous saoulez pour les
victimes les gens Solveig
[Applaudissements]
on va écouter quelqu'un d'autre sauter
dans les arènes
je pense que je peux faire elle veut une
pizza
alors Mathieu tu as un truc à lui dire
ben non mais c'est dommage d'être
fasciste et tout ça parce que moi enfin
pour le coup on était très nombreux en
grande majorité
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui quelle que
soit les traditions tout grandissent par
animal doit disparaître exactement dans
les cirques que les abattoirs
que ce soit effectivement les corridas
c'est une honte même dans ce cas là
c'est pas la souffrance qu'on a même
arrêté les animaux sur les plateaux
depuis des années que les animaux
pouvaient pouvaient tomber amoureux
pouvaient pleurer pour être stressé donc
aujourd'hui quel que soit effectivement
le le le le voilà les traditions pardon
toute souffrance animale doit être
arrêtée point bah je suis très choqué
effectivement Géraldine
loi la proposition de loi qui a été
faite par Aymeric Caron était refusé
avant même qu'on puisse la beauté parce
qu'effectivement je ne pense pas que oui
elle a été retiré
même pas
les députés représentent la France et on
est quand même très nombreux aujourd'hui
à penser au contraire qu'il faut arrêter
les bobos tu vas à Dax tu vas à
Mont-de-Marsan qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire que les provinceaux sont des
bourrins et que la souffrance
il y a quelqu'un qui a changé les piles
[Applaudissements]
bon bah ça y est je suis arrivé avec
leurs parents chez nous on bouffe on
fait peut-être fâché sur le plateau
alors qu'on parle de la corrida
la corrida Bolloré est en
[Rires]
faut prendre du gaviscon
j'aimerais j'aimerais que elle nous
insultes c'est comme ça alors que vous
vous êtes vous êtes comme exactement
[Rires]
des millions d'animaux comptent nous qui
mangeons de la viande on peut se sentir
coupable
de millions d'années
gastronomie arrêtez de taper sur votre
micro c'est insupportable alors nous on
fait quoi
une maladie au canards et on lui bouffe
le foie après on va commencer Béatrice à
la base je suis contre la corrida parce
qu'effectivement la souffrance animale
je trouve ça insupportable maintenant je
vous je trouve que c'est hypocrite de
parler uniquement de la corrida alors
que les lois sur les étourdissements
dans les abattoirs ne sont pas respectés
vive les pistolets pour vous
elle vous a la même position
que le pistolet qui défonce le crâne
d'une victime
[Rires]
à mon avis elle fait ça pour capter
je crois que là elle était en Edge non
mais c'est vrai alors la Béatrice
ouvrez les cons de la mort ouvrez les
candidats
jamais avec ça j'étais en train de vous
détruire toute seule alors
Mathieu
le micro dans le cucus c'était pour toi
c'est pas pour Solveig bien sûr
toutes les qui se battent bravo Nathalie
Valentin bravo voilà c'est une pratique
d'homme sadique c'est dans la semaine on
est des hommes on est contre mon chou
enfin quand même vous défendez une belle
cause vous la gâchez une fois de plus
elle avait dit qu'elle serait calme elle
avait dit qu'elle serait calme tu te
ridiculises la barre des deux millions
hein je te le dis
ils ont inventé le porno du
service sur le porno maintenant on a
changé de débat des choses
le monsieur qui nous a tué avec son
micro là il y a pourtant vous mettez
tous les hommes dans le même truc
la corrida c'est les hommes donc tous
les hommes sont dégueulasses et les
barbecues c'est les hommes
et la pollution
[Applaudissements]
contre les peuples victimes le peuple
des fables le peuple des autres animaux
le peuple des enfants ce sont ils
assassinent des bébés ils assassinent
des petits veaux dans les arènes ils
assassinent des chevaux qu'ils utilisent
dans un seul perverses
tu délires totalement là reprends
je suis content
que la Florida assassine des enfants ah
ça c'est la corrida assassine pas
d'enfants sur le mec reprend toi alors
sale Bègue merci sur le bec petit bon
dans les arènes monsieur ne sait pas
encore là
il a pas pu parler il aimait la mission
micro toutes les missions il nous a
saoulé
elle elle arrête pas de parler qu'est-ce
que je voudrais juste dire
une heure à mettre son micro parler
sont dirigés comme par des personnes
comme Solveig Alloin extremiste et
j'invite les gens à venir découvrir la
corrida oui aux arènes à visiter les
élevages ils ont tous les bienvenus et
voilà le vrai visage du militantisme
anti-coïdara